which actually resulted in the facebook
award for networking however
bill discovered that he that is not so
much into network
synthesis although he still uh works on
this topic even he has a paper this year
at nsdi
but he's actually more interested in
programming languages and
synthesis from that perspective so i'm
looking forward to hear his talk
uh some work that you will see today are
already published they must
are still under uh uh sufficient
preparations
so we will very much really appreciate
your feedback so thank you very much
bill for the great to give a talk and
they're looking forward to hear more
thank you
sorry i got a notification that i was
muted still
i didn't know how to do that without
stopping sharing okay thank you for the
introduction
um my name's bill hallahan um
i'll be speaking about counterexample
guided inference of modular
specifications
so uh really what this talk is about is
how to use
synthesis to make verification tools
um work better and make it easier to
work with verification tools
um and so i'm going to be showing
programs in haskell syntax
um and so this is a
map function and it takes a function as
input and it takes a list and it gives
us back the list
and the way it produces this list is
just applies the function to each
element
of the input list we can give
this function some uh specification
uh so we're naming the input list x's
and the output list y's
and then we're saying that the size of
the input list should be equal to the
size of the output list
and if we give this to a verifier uh we
expect that
this property is true and indeed the
verifier will be able to tell us that
this property is true
uh so more particularly i'm going to be
speaking about a class of verifiers
called modular verifiers
uh and in particular the code that i'm
showing here is for a verifier called
liquid haskell but there's other modular
verifiers you might be familiar with so
daphne and esc java
are also modular verifiers and
um we can see what makes modular
verification unique from this example
i have this add two function and i'm
saying that the output should be exactly
two more than the input
and to implement add two i'm calling a
functioning anchor twice
so let's look at anchor anchor
specification says that its output is
greater than its input
and it's implemented by calling by just
adding one
to the input so hopefully it seems
believable to all of you
these specifications are true um
and so you might expect and because
they're pretty simple that if we gave
this to a verifier it would just say
yes good your code is correct uh but in
fact
modular verifiers um don't look at
functions definitions when trying to
verify
callers they only look at specifications
and so what that means is that when a
modular verifier is trying to prove that
add2 specification is correct
it won't see this whole picture it will
only see this piece of it we'll know
that in crew's output is greater than
its input
but it won't know anything else um
and so because knowing that the output
of anchor is reading its input is not
specific enough to know that
the output of add2 is exactly two more
than the input verification here will
actually fail
and to get verification to succeed we
need a stronger specification on anchor
that says that the output of anchor is
exactly one more than its input
now here this example it's a bit trivial
we can easily see
you know maybe why the specification is
wrong um as we get to larger examples
with more
complicated functions and more
complicated specifications it becomes
harder and harder to do this
um so here we have this concat function
that takes a list of list of a's
um and it returns a list of a's and
um it gets this list by just joining all
of the
the lists and the list of lists together
and the specification we have says that
if we sum up the sizes
of all the lists in the input list of
lists
uh that should be equal to the size of
the output list
and to implement concat we've made use
of this append function
that just takes two lists and appends
the first list of the second list
um if we gave this to our
modular verifier as is um it's not gonna
be able to prove this property
because we don't have any specification
for app and so in concat
the verifier is going to know nothing
about what app is doing
um so we could begin
trying to write our own specification
for app and and trying to figure out
what do we need
to tell the verified verifier about apps
to get this to work
um but that's a bit of a pain it becomes
more and more of a pain as we scale the
larger and larger programs
um and so the question we're going to
try to answer in this talk is how can we
automatically find
the required specifications
um before i try to answer that i want to
step back a bit um
and talk briefly about some work that um
i previously did with my collaborators
and it was published at pldi 2019
um because this previous work kind of
led to our current work
um and then this work we were trying to
answer um a slightly different question
we weren't trying to automatically find
specifications but we were trying to
help
um programmers working with modular
verifiers debug the errors that the
modular verifiers were getting them
uh and so the plan in this work was um
the user would take their code and their
specifications
and give them to the verifier and
hopefully the verifier just works
right off the bat um and we know the
code is verified
um but if that doesn't happen we had the
centric tool named g2
and g2 is a symbolic execution engine
that can produce two kinds of
counter examples uh to help explain why
modular verification is failing
the first kind of counterexample is
called a concrete counter example
and this is just an input output pair
that satisfies the specification
but that causes a violation of the
specification
and so this is what you might kind of
traditionally think of as a counter
example
abstract counter examples are to help
debug in the cases
where um the specifications are actually
correct
but the verifier can't show that um and
so what an abstract count example does
is it points out a function that needs
um or a function that likely needs a
stronger specification
and how that specification needs to be
stronger um and i'll be showing some
examples of abstract counter examples in
just a little bit
um for now though i'll say what we
noticed after writing this paper was
we can maybe actually do one better um
rather than forcing the programmer to
take
abstract count examples and try to fix
the code themselves
we can turn this into a seagus loop um
and when you get an abstract counter
example we can give that to a
synthesizer that will come up with a new
uh specification and then we can give
that specification back to the verifier
um and if we get a concrete counter
example it's one of these synthesized
classifications we can also just give
that to the synthesizer and
tell it use this concrete count example
to fix the specification you came up
with before
um and so um as promised i'm going to
talk a bit
more about what exactly abstract counter
examples and
also foreign examples are um and then
i'll touch on how this whole
loop works and show an example of that
um and then i'll
finish by um talking a bit more about
the synthesizer and specifically how we
built a synthesizer
for this problem using uh linear integer
arithmetic
uh or to find linear integer from text
specifications
um so beginning by talking about counter
examples
um as i said we have two types concrete
counter examples um
are showing when the code is actually
incorrect so here i have that map
function from before
except i've uh messed up the recursive
case by just removing
um appending f of x so um
this map function will always return an
empty list um
and the concrete counter example here
shows exactly that
um if we apply map this incorrect map to
the identity and a list of one in it
we get an empty list back
um now abstract count examples are
helping us debug in the case
um of like the add to an anchor function
that i showed before
where the code is correct specifications
are too weak
um and so here's what the abstract
counter example that we get
looks like um it says that add 2 of zero
is equal to query
if anchor of zero is equal to um
so the point here is the specification
of anchor
uh is not sufficient to tell us that
anchor of zero is not equal to
um and so the modular verifier might
think that anchor of zero equals two
um and if the modular verifier thinks
that inc of z equals two
then it will think that add two of zero
might equal three
um and so the way we have to fix this is
strengthen the specification to tell
on anchor to tell the modular verifier
no and groove zero does not equal two
so arms with these counter examples um
we can form a
c gis loop um and to demonstrate how
this works i'm going to go back to the
concat
uh append example that i had before
um and of course if you're on the
verifier on this verification is not
going to succeed
and so we can use g2 to get an abstract
counter example that
helps explain why um and so this
abstract counter example says that
if we call from cat on a list of two
empty lists in it we might get the list
zero
uh or list of zero in it if appending
two empty lists
gets us a list of zero in it
um and from this abstract candidate we
can form
a constraint that must hold uh on the
specification for amp it must tell us
that if
um the two inputs to app are both empty
lists
then the post condition of amp cannot
allow the output to be a list with zero
in it
um and we can actually just run app
on two empty lists and see what it does
um it gives us an empty list
and so this gives us another synthesis
constraint um telling us something that
the specification of your app must
satisfy must allow an empty list to be
returned
um so if we give these constraints to a
synthesizer
we can get a possible specification for
app um
and here the specification we come up
came up with is that the
size of the output list is always zero
now of course this is not a correct
specification
and so if we try to verify this we'll
fail uh and then we can use g2 to get
a concrete counter example telling us
well actually if you
apply append to a list of zero in it an
empty list you get a list of zero in it
um and this gets us another system
stream um
and again we come up with a
specification that's not quite correct
and so we keep on getting
counter examples um and eventually if we
continue this long enough
we'll come up the specification that the
size of the output list has to be equal
to the size of the input list
uh oh sorry the size of the output list
has to be equal to the sum of the sizes
of the input lists
um and uh the verifier will be able to
verify the code given the specification
so um in some ways this is a
bit of a complicated example we have a
list we have lists of lists we have
these functions of replies lists
um but it's also fairly simple and that
it's really just two functions it's
concat and app and in a real world
program you're going to have a much
larger
uh college graph with many more
functions in it
and ideally what would like programmers
be able to do is write down a single
specification that kind of says here's
my high level intent for this whole
module or this whole program um and they
would like to come up with
specifications for all of the other
functions
um to be able to support this this high
level specification
and the way we're going to be able to do
this is by splitting the color graph
into levels so the root of the color
graph has level one
uh and then every other um
functions level is its distance from the
group
and the plan we're going to follow is
we're going to walk down the color graph
um from level one to the lowest level
and at each level um we're going to try
to come up with specifications for the
level below
that let us prove the specifications for
the level above so
initially we're going to say okay we
have a specification for f
let's come up with specifications for h
and g
um that if those specifications are true
would let us prove the specification of
graph is true
and once we have those we'll go to h
we'll say okay let's come to
specifications for the functions called
by h
that would let us prove the
specification of h
um and ideally we'll just walk down the
college graph once
and we'll come up with the direct
specifications and verify the code
um now of course we don't live in a
perfect world so
sometimes we might guess a specification
that is incorrect
um and in that case we'll rely on
backtracking um
and we'll be able to know we have to
backtrack in two cases um
the first case is we might get a
concrete counter example that shows
that some previous specification that we
came up with is actually incorrect
um and the second case is we might hit a
point where
um the underlying synthesizer that's
coming up with specifications
um encounters a problem that's
unrealizable
um and in both of these cases we
backtrack and the key point is
uh when we backtrack we um
always have a new constraint that
prevents us from just re-traversing the
exact same set of specifications again
um so in the case of a concrete counter
example being found that new constraint
just comes from the concrete counter
example um
and when the synthesistron becomes
unrealizable we
rely on the synthesizer being able to
produce an interpolant that explains
why the problem was unrealizable and we
add that as a constraint
um so now i'm going to talk a bit more
about how this synthesizer
uh actually works um in particular how
we built a synthesizer that synthesizes
uh
leo specifications um
so the synthesizer takes um the
constraints
and the measures which are these size
and some size functions that
um let us kind of access information
about lists
um but in general they could also let us
access information about other data
structures um
and it's going to produce either the
result that the problem is realizable
um and in that case we'll give us a
specification uh or it's going to
produce a result that the
uh problem is unrealizable and will give
us an interpolant
um and we're going to build the
synthesizer
um using smt solver uh to synthesize
these leah constraints
um and we want to make the job of the
smt solver as easy as possible so we
wanted to only be having to deal with
integers as inputs and outputs uh but
this poses a bit of a problem because of
course as you've seen
we don't only have integers in our
problems we have lists and we have these
functions being applied to lists and we
have
um the ability to nest
uh specifications inside lists i'll show
that in a second
um uh
and so we need to do some translation
from these more complicated constraints
into problems over just integers and
then we need to do a translation back
um so i'm going to focus on how we do
these translations
um so let's look at an example
um of a function uh we have this
function f that takes two integers and
returns a list events
um and all it does is add adds four to
both of the input integers and then
sticks them in a list
um so it's not a very complicated
function um
but there's three ways we can write
specifications for this
um we can write specifications that are
directly applied to
um the integer literals that are inputs
or outputs
so here we're seeing that one of the
integers has to be negative and one of
the integers has to be positive
um we can apply a measure to the list
input
so we can say for example that the size
of the list input has to be
uh has to be not we can say that then
list input has to be non-empty
um or we can talk about the contents of
the list
um so we can say that all of the
integers
in the list have to be greater than zero
uh so encoding integers that are already
just integers
into the um synthesizer is not very
interesting um
because the synthesizer deals with
integers and the
specification already just has integers
um so i'm going to focus on how we
deal with encoding these measures and
adt contents
um so beginning with measures uh let's
look at some specific constraints so
here we're saying that if the
precondition of f
is satisfied by zero and one the post
condition must be satisfied by zero one
and a list for four and five in it um
and what's fortunate for us is that
these constraints are always talking
about concrete values
um and so we can know that the size of
the list
for five is two so then when we give a
constraint to the
synthesizer instead of giving it the
list for five
we can just give it the value to and
when we get a solution that uses that
input we'll
we'll look something like post f x y z
equals z greater than zero
and when we're translating that back
into a specification
uh we just know that instead of having
just c there we need
uh the size of z
to deal with um finding specifications
over the contents
of lists uh we introduce a new post
condition function
uh that i'm calling postdefcons here
and we'll use this in addition to post f
um so post f is still encoding things
about the size of the list
and post def cons is encoding things
about the content so we say that post
def cons has to hold on 0 1
4 and 0 1 5 because 4 and 5 are the
contents of the list
and then if we come up with some
solution that makes use of post f cons
so for example that says
that uh the return value has to be
greater than two in in
both cases um we can again translate
this into a specification just by
sticking that um into inside the list to
say apply this to the contents of the
list
so to evaluate this um we ran our
interference algorithm
on 15 benchmarks both created by us
and drawn from a graduate student level
class homework assignment
um so here are running times for 14 of
the benchmarks
um all of the benchmarks involve um
greatest sex or recursive functions um
and the fact the functions recursive
means that simpler techniques like just
inline it would not be
applicable to any of these benchmarks
um the benchmark that i'm not showing
here um is significantly larger than all
of the
um other benchmarks it involves 34
functions and is the inner loop of a key
means implementation
um you were able to prove that um be
able to prove certain properties of this
k means implementation
uh in about 596 seconds
um so that's slightly under 10 minutes
so in conclusion um i've discussed our
inference algorithm uh to come up with
specifications for modular verifiers
and how we built a synthesizer to find
these specifications
uh find julia specifications
thank you and i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you bill let's start with the
questions are there some questions with
the audience
um so bill there is a question uh sadly
do you want to just
unmute yourself and ask or
if not then i can read it so the
question says
uh what what were the specifications for
functions like map
uh or reverse
um so the um
right yes so most of these um
are actually the format of them was we
had the map function of the reverse
function
and then we had some um property that we
were trying to prove
um so i don't remember exactly what the
property was
for map but it would have been something
like the length of the
it would have been something like the
length of x's is equal to the length
of map f x's um
and similarly for reverse it might have
been something like x's
the length of reverse reverse x's is
equal to x length of x's or maybe even a
script line reverse ones i
i can't i'm not i don't remember exactly
but it was it was property functions
about these
um underlying list functions
add more questions let's see
uh bill nice talk can i can i trouble
you to go back to the slide where you
talked about the
going from layer k down to lever
layer one and what happens there
it'll be easier for me to formulate my
question
um so so so the specifications you
synthesize
for modules functions are specific to
the user provided specification right
kind of tailored to that
and since you walk down the graph
um
uh you so what what can happen right you
are starting from the user goal
essentially
and it could happen that the
specifications say for
h or g or such would be
what too abstract to prove the goal at
the top level and that then needs to be
refined using the counter examples
that's that's the idea
yes exactly so how how how do you
decompose the spec
at level i to the lower level of
what is the reasoning that could lead to
specifications that are too abstract
yeah sorry go ahead no go go ahead i'm
not sure i can completely understand the
question
so well you wanna prove something at
level one
and you express that your goal is now
express it in terms of sub goals right
the sub goals are the levels 2 in this
case
and as you create these sub goals
they need to be strong enough to prove
the original
goal right yes so they cannot be
too abstract exactly
so where can the specification
then be wrong i guess i'm missing yeah i
see
so the way the specification can be
drawn it so
right at level one we're going to be
trying to prove we're going to try to
prove graph
um and so we're going to come up with
specifications for h and g that let us
prove
the specification graph if these
specifications are true
um but we're only picking these
specifications based on the
counter examples that we've seen so far
so it's possible that we'll come up with
a specification
for h or g that
if that specification was true would let
us prove f but that specification isn't
actually true
so for example maybe um to prove f
we need all we need to know is that h
returns
um or maybe to prove f we come up with
specification that h
returns um numbers strictly greater than
zero
and maybe there actually is some way
that h can return zero
um and so in that case we'll um
have to backtrack and come up with a new
specification for age that says that
h can return uh numbers non-strictly
greater than zero
so the specification for age is then not
created in this sort of deductive way
where
in order to prove something about f i
need the following thing about
age and if that is true then i can prove
things about
f it is essentially the spec for age is
entirely data driven and kind of bottom
up right
um well i think it is
it is definitely data driven
um i mean so we only move on to trying
to
prove this respect for h um
once we know that this the spec we have
for h
would be sufficient to prove the
spectrograph um
so i kind of think of it as is top down
for that
reason um but it is
also true that we're not um
i mean we could learn new things and
have to back up
we could learn new things about what
each is doing and have to back up
um okay thank you
i think you have the correct picture of
how it works anyway um
thank you bill i appreciate the answer
let me see at the more questions
uh okay let me just quickly uh
oh sorry there is a more question excuse
me
uh super predict would you like to
comment or shall i read
oh sorry no that's answering his
previous question i'm sorry it's not
related to you bill
so let's then uh stop here
and maybe okay now let's really stop
here because so that we finish in time
week and
if you would like to know more uh please
uh contact the bill he will gladly tell
you more okay
thank you everyone bye-bye